that uh
brooklyn wizards game
uh
assistant coach for the nets
david banterpool
knocking this pass away
i think that was an accident yeah he
thought the ball was going out of bounds
yeah right but it's five minutes and 44
seconds left in the game you had a lot
more time than that one possession
though
it was it was crazy
come on jack you got those crazy you
don't see that every day do you i agree
with professor chuck it was an accident
uh derrick's get your hand up bernie
just put your hand up for a second just
just make a move see it's accident that
wasn't an accident you told me to do it
let's look at this again you think it
was an accident yeah i think cause look
at it after the fact he's like oh i
think that touched the ball
like watch his act his his reaction
afterwards he's like yeah my bad my bad
but you know what the referee should be
paying attention well derek stafford's
one of the referees he's like oh he's
right there next to him you know what's
the referee right next to him that guy
right there they won the game by one
point derrick stafford that was five
minutes at 45 cents i know i know but in
a one point game
i'm not saying that's why they lost no
but they were saying it they had a whole
press conference about it yeah well it
was an interesting look you know all
they got to do is just blame frank vogel
or russell westbrook
speaking of russell getting benched last
night in the fourth quarter of that loss
they blow a 15 point lead to the indiana
pacers and lose at home you know i
normally don't root against teams
because i don't i think that's that's
not the i could only i don't give a rat
to win these games of what
rats has which how big is that but i
really thought have you not heard that
phrase before well i mean well normally
right
can i make my point
i'd love to pursue that first i just
want to say i you know so i never
i don't because i don't care who wins i
mean i just want the season be over so
we can go play golf and fish all right
let's uh but i root uh the lakers are
such wussies and all i say what's this
because i can't say the word i wanna i
know the way they have trying to throw
russell westbrook
and frank vogel under the bus it's just
really pissing me off and i got to tell
you something no hey you know we've got
to we've got a guest stand in mind well
the lakers still suck when we get back
from his interview okay okay
well
campaign i don't know if you've caught
all that but welcome to the show we
appreciate you very much man yes i
appreciate it